the CW's crossover event is reaching out
to the live-action TV and film
adaptations of the past and present to
weave as many characters as possible
into crisis as rich tapestry heroes and
villains are falling and rising worlds
are dying and the cameos flow freely
from here on in be prepared for spoilers
crisis on Infinite Earths doesn't waste
any time before it pays fanservice to
popular DC superhero adaptations of old
part one of the crossover opens with
cameos from across classic comic book
films and TV beginning with Robert wuhl
reprising his role as ambitious
investigative reporter Alexander knocks
on earth 89 Wolff played knocks the only
reporter in Gotham who believed Batman
was real and was determined to find out
who he was in Tim Burton's 1989 Batman
movie surprise stuff that we never learn
if Knox's coverage of the Dark Knight
wins in the acclaim he always wanted but
judging by the paper he's reading Batman
coverage is at least a little more
mainstream these days among the myriad
of different worlds were shown
succumbing to in the antimatter wave in
the opening minutes of crisis on
Infinite Earths is Earth 9 we see only
two young heroes faces before the end
comes and if you're not familiar with
the DC Universe streaming services
original programming you might not have
any idea who they are both heroes hail
from DC universes very first original
series Titans the hero in the red and
white suit is Hawk and the younger hero
in the Domino mask is Robin specifically
this Robin is Jason Todd who in the
comics is the second boy to take on the
name Robin eventually dying violently at
the hands of the Joker their appearance
and crisis confirms that Titans world
exists within the same multiverse or at
least it used to exist in the same
multiverse the final cameo from crisis
part ones cold-open is from one of DC
Comics earliest live-action adaptations
Burt Ward who played Robin alongside
Adam West in the 60s camp series Batman
is walking his dog in Gotham City as the
antimatter wave hits earth 66 while he
doesn't appear to be crime-fighting
anymore the neckline on wards shirt has
a black
green pattern reminiscent of Robins
old-school costume and if that along
with the signature Batman theme song
aren't enough to let you know exactly
who this is his single line of dialogue
should do the trick one of the more fun
surprises in crisis is the return of Jon
Cryer as Superman's arch nemesis
billionaire Lex Luthor by the end of
crisis part 3 he's stolen the book of
Destiny twice and tried to murder
multiple versions of Superman he
eventually succeeds in murdering the
Superman of earth 96 replacing him as
the paragon of truth the return of
Criers Lex Luthor is noteworthy for a
number of reasons not only as Cryer
perfect in the rule but he's a DC
adaptation alumnus Cryer plays Lex
Luthor's annoying nephew Lenny in the
1987 bomb Superman for the quest for
peace in the crisis aftermath after show
following crisis part 3 Cryer told Kevin
Smith he saw his casting as Luthor as a
chance to redeem that earlier flop yeah
you're just an experiment free kill
no the monitor played by Lamonica
Garrett is a character lifted directly
from the original DC Comics event crisis
on Infinite Earths when the multiverse
was created most universes were
comprised of positive matter
but there was one made of antimatter the
monitor is a living breathing avatar for
the positive matter in the universe
while the anti-monitor is his opposite
in the antimatter universe each is
instantly aware of the other and they
battle for millenia just as it happens
in the TV event the comics crossover
sees the monitor recruits superheroes to
help and just like the end of part 3 of
CW's crisis in the comic it's a
corrupted version of Harbinger that
kills the godlike being the character
Harbinger is proof that the creative
teams behind the arrowverse have had
crisis in the back of their minds for
longer than you might realize
audrey marie anderson has played Lyla
Michaels on arrow since 2013 she
originally shows up as John diggle's
ex-wife and she eventually replaces
Amanda Waller as the head of the
clandestine group Argus John Diggle and
Lyla reunite and have a son well it was
a daughter at first but then Barry time
travelled and their daughter became a
son it's complicated and with the coming
of crisis Lyla is transformed into the
monitor's protege Harbinger fans of the
comics have probably expected something
like this was coming for a while in the
main Crisis storyline LaMichael becomes
Harbinger just about immediately and
works with the godlike being to prepare
for the crisis just as it happens in the
CW event in the comics Harbinger is
corrupted by the anti-monitor and used
to kill the monitor after lex luthor
gets his hands on the book of destiny in
crisis part two he decides to wipe out
every Superman in every reality the
vengeful quest brings him to a man
chopping wood at a farm who has no s on
his chest and little patience for Lex in
case you couldn't tell by the flannel
the man is Clark Kent
played by Tom Welling from the hit
series Smallville in crisis part 2 we
learn that since the conclusion of
Smallville Clark has given up his powers
and settled into a simpler life when Jon
Cryer's Lex Luthor travels to earth
67 to deal with Kent the revelation that
this Superman gave up his powers makes
him furious with confusion and disbelief
who gave up your powers can't say I miss
these chests as soon as images began
emerging of brandon ralph as the
Superman of Earth 96 in crisis it was
clear that this take on Superman was
heavily inspired by the 1996 comic
Kingdom comma throughout Superman outfit
particularly the black included in the
Superman insignia is very reminiscent of
that version but of course this isn't
just a callback to a comic Brandon Routh
was tapped to play Superman even though
he already has a narrow vers role as
Earth Ones atom on legends of tomorrow
because the actor stepped into Supes red
boots in 2006 is Superman Returns in
part 2 of CW's crisis on Infinite Earths
crossover that woman and Supergirl
traveled to Earth 99 to recruit who they
believe is the multiverses Paragon of
courage that Earth's version of Batman
so the Paragard of courage is apparently
afraid of yardwork better let me do the
talking
instead of a Paragon the pair find a
bitter angry Bruce Wayne who is a dark
fusion of different versions of The Dark
Knight Kevin Conroy best known as the
Batman of the animated series has given
his voice to Gotham's protector in
numerous animated TV film and video game
projects for the past 27 years in crisis
part 2 he physically portrays the Dark
Knight for the first time although it
isn't the version we expected we learned
that this version of Wayne would
eventually resort to murder to achieve
his goals including killing his world
Superman before his death Wayne tells
Supergirl something interesting my
parents taught me a very different
lesson life only makes sense if you
force it
this line comes almost word-for-word
from the 1986 comic Batman The Dark
Knight Returns from Batman's narration
as he fights Superman though even that
darker realization of Bruce Wayne
doesn't seek to kill Clark ever since
Tom Cavanagh as original flash character
Harrison wells bit the dust it seems
we've gotten new alternate Earth's
version of wells every season this
season of flash begins with a version of
the character named Nash wells who has a
bit of an Indiana Jones flair but that
changes when he unintentionally frees
the anti-monitor and causes the crisis
as punishment wells is made into pariah
and is forced to witness tragedy as it
unfolds things work a bit differently in
the comics in the crisis comics pariahs
real name is Kel Massa
Cal conducts experiments allowing him to
see the birth of the universe but in
doing so attracts the attention of the
anti-monitor who destroys mosses earth
the monitor saves pariahs life and gives
him the ability to travel from earth to
earth witnessing as each is destroyed
crisis part 3 opens in new Gotham on
earth 203 with a hero running from the
antimatter wave unlike many of the
multiverse cameos we've seen in crisis
we actually get to see as the wave hits
the hero killing her the hero is
Huntress played by Ashley Scott from the
2002 to 2003 TV series birds of prey and
the Huntress and you're the prey
Huntress wasn't the only hero on the
show over her comms we hear the voice of
Oracle formerly known as Batgirl becomes
the intelligence arm of the birds of
prey after she's paralyzed by a bullet
from the Joker in crisis part 3 team
flashes Cisco Ramon joins the efforts to
find the multiverses Paragons and his
efforts lead them to a scientist named
Ryan Choi the paragon of humanity he's
unique among the Paragons in that he
isn't a superhero or super villain
though if the source material is any
gauge that won't stay true for long in
the DC Comics Ryan Choi first fills Ray
Palmer's place by taking his job at Ivy
University and later taking on his
abilities as the new version of the
drinking here Oh Adam choice solo series
all new Adam folded after 25 issues
though he remains Adam in the comics
he's eventually murdered by Deathstroke
but after DC's line wide new 52 reboot
and the subsequent event convergence
Choi returns to the narrative he
appeared in the most recent Justice
League of America series as the atom
alongside an eccentric lineup that
included Batman Lobo and killer frost
perhaps no one should have been shocked
that crisis part 3 features a cameo by
Tom Ellis as Lucifer Morningstar the
lead of Netflix's Lucifer and yes the
devil himself after all the world that
John Constantine John Diggle and Mia
Smoak travel to is earth 666 Netflix DC
Comics and the CW largely have Neil
Gaiman to thank for this version of
Lucifer the character first appears in
gaymans classic Sandman series as an
adversary to its hero and later got a
solo comic series Lucifer which was then
adapted into a TV series for Fox Lucifer
was cancelled by Fox after its third
season but the series was picked up by
Netflix in June 2019 we learned that
Lucifer had been renewed for a fifth and
final season on the streaming service
crisis part 3 sees the return and
sacrifice of the flash of Earth 90 last
year CW crossover Elseworlds opened with
this version of the flash being the sole
surviving hero on earth 90 he soon
joined the arrowverse heroes to face the
monitor but disappeared early in the
crossover without a trace we now know
where he was as a prisoner of the
anti-monitor birth 90 flash was forced
to run a treadmill that powered the
antimatter wave toward the end of crisis
part 3 he sacrifices himself to stop the
wave and save earth 1 this isn't just
another alternate universe flash played
by john wesley shipp this flash is the
same hero who was the lead for the
short-lived the flash series from 1990
to 91
thanks flash please some way around here
knows how to rescue a kid CW's the flash
has never been lazy about paying tribute
to its predecessor ship has played
multiple roles on the flash including
versions of the hero from other worlds
ever since Oliver Queen's death at the
end of crisis part 1 the heroes have
been searching for a way to bring him
back to life in part two they bring his
body to a Lazarus Pit on an alternate
earth but they managed to revive Green
Arrow's body but not his soul John
Constantine does his best to bring back
Queen Sol but in part three they're
forced to travel to purgatory to
retrieve it directly after a tearful
reunion
it seems that Oliver will return to the
land of the living until a mysterious
man named Jim Corrigan appears if you're
a DC Comics fan then that name means a
lot Jim Corrigan is a former police
detective who takes on the role of the
spectre a powerful entity who in some
incarnations is meant to be the literal
wrath of God in the comics Corrigan was
eventually replaced as the host for the
spectre by the Green Lantern Hal Jordan
who had died in the 1996 event final
night the fact that Corrigan appears
when he does and stops Oliver Queen from
crossing over back to the land of the
living suggests that it may now be
Oliver Queen who is called upon to be
the host of The Spectre check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]